we are here with none other than the
extraordinary brothers clint and ron
howard
if you don't mind i would love to pick
both of your brains because we've talked
about your family but i mean we all have
such an insight into our lives through
your work will you give us a fly on the
wall behind the scenes moment on some of
your most famous collaborations of
course okay it's something we call
behind the scenes
um okay i love night shift the movie so
much what was i also just think it has
one of the most interesting tones
well it was brian grazer my partner at
imagine entertainment it was his idea
and it was our and it was the first time
we ever worked together on you know on a
movie it was based on our on an article
he he read in
in the new york times that somebody had
been you know arrested
for running a a prostitution ring out of
the new york city morgue
this was
not a true story but it was inspired by
that article and um gans and mandel who
are happy days writers and show runners
and brilliant comedy writers they took
it and they and they and they ran with
it and somehow they they shaped
something that was that was a little
sexy a little naughty very raucous and
still utterly human and and and
connected to you know love and respect
and henry winkler got it green lit by
agreeing to be in it and then michael
keaton was discovered through it and it
was of joy
i mean
he is a revelation
and then he went on to become one of the
biggest movie stars on the planet yes um
what clint was your story from night
shift well my story is it was a good
movie because ron cast me in a role
where i got to lay in a morgue drawer
with a naked woman
that's right and you you go back in you
come out but you're like no no
this is what it's like and the more
drawer shuts um okay
i can't even say this movie without
saying i think this is the film that
changed our lives the most
parenthood oh
thank you thank you
it's probably the most personal film
that i've ever made because so many of
those stories came from one or the other
of us gans mandel brian grazer telling
stories about you know sort of his
childhood but also his his years as a
dad and uh my daughter bryce uh was the
projectile vomiter
[Laughter]
and the whole idea for the movie
actually came because we went on this
unbelievably long
flight to argentina with the kids and my
job was to sit with uh bryce and uh and
i said they brought around some
vegetarian sushi
and uh in a roll you know with rice and
i said hey you want to try this bryce
and she said okay and i thought i was
being a really good dad she was four
years old she's going to try a little
vegetarian sushi she ate it chewed it
ate another bite shoot it about another
four minutes
i got hit with projectile vomit all over
my shirt in hour one of a 17-hour flight
and i and i just thought no one told me
about being a dad
no one said what it was gonna be like um
alicia you wanted to ask about a movie
yes um i want to ask about
your directing cocoon well first of all
cocoon was a fantastic important project
for me because i wasn't working with
brian grazer and all my close friends i
was working with these legendary
actors and an incredible producer
richard zanik it was also
my mom didn't have a real pardon dad had
a part clint had a part
mom was just beginning to show a little
interest in getting back into the
business
and she i i asked her to be an extra
and she gained a lot of confidence and
she also befriended all of the women
maureen stapleton gwen verdon jessica
tandy
and and and she also came away from it
with this story she said you know i
talked to all of them about going
through their lives pursuing their
careers trying to balance family trying
to balance relationships and it made me
feel like i actually made a very good
decision
but it but it also
i now think it's time to try to go back
in and so that on a personal level that
was a kind of a breakthrough of course i
have to ask about another one of my very
favorite films splash
[Applause]
well i was actually working on that film
as a pa
and i'm in that movie because the fellow
who was supposed to play that part was a
no-show
and i i they think ron came to me and
goes hey would you like to do this
little part in this scene you know i
don't think i said would you like to
you're going to
we were shooting at disney in burbank
and i that's where i was living at the
time and i went home i got my suit
because it was at the wedding i came
back i did my bit
and they said okay that's a wrap on
clint howard you know
to play the part and i said oh great
guys and i started to leave
and ron goes where are you going bud
get your walkie-talkie yeah and i said
listen i'm wrapped and he goes no you're
not get your walkie-talkie so back to
work
i love how you guys work side by side
always
and clint i know that you like snow
globes
yeah i've made a few
he creates them he creates snow globes
that's right you make them um in fact i
saw this picture on instagram and we
wanted to give you a little gift
um
yes thank you so much oh wow
that is a beautiful thing wait you're
reading the book in the snow globe
that's right yes that's that's why we
did it thank you great momentum yes i i
i am ready
i am reading the book so maybe i'll make
it into one of your photographs one day
um thank you drew that's awesome thank
you very much thank you so much for
coming on this show and representing
siblings and just making all of our
lives much better the boys a memoir of
hollywood and family is available
right now i can't love it more please
read it it's just wonderful thank you
guys
[Music]